hey we're taking apart and iMac 2011 mid
2011 21 inch and it's got a bad
harddrive we got these special plungers
and took off the front protector panel
and I think it's a t8 t 6 or t8 and took
out all this all the screws sorry this
is probably hard to understand there's
screws on each side four on each side
and then are over here anyway I took
them all out and now I'm gonna pull off
the screen and I just want to document a
little there's some wires here that we
have to pull this forward and connect
these wires and I'll be back I'll try to
explain as best I can so I've got a
rough explanation I'm doing this on a
whim but myzel document
okay I've uncut connected those four
cables that were hooked to the screen
and I should mention there is a hardware
maintenance hardware maintenance manual
you can get for this I'll try to provide
the link below I couldn't actually find
it easily but it did find it before
however the reason I'm just going ahead
and doing this is I used to do this for
a living so I have done this a million
times with this model well not literally
a million but many times so I know what
I'm doing the most part but if you're
looking at this video because you want
to do this for the first time go look at
that manual it has step-by-step
instructions of what you will need
alright see it has a list of all the
tools you will need so you can go
purchase them I have this multi kid that
helps but you can get official tools too
and also it has step-by-step
instructions of how to take this apart
so I am NOT following those obviously
since I don't have it but I kind of know
what to do anyway but yes you need
suction cups
you need these special screwdrivers I
think a t6 and a t8 all right I want to
go ahead and get to the hard drive
that's my goal here I'll be back shortly
okay I remove that screen as you can see
the hard drives right here it looks like
it's just some screws
where they they look like t eights maybe
just four up there I'm not even sure if
you have to do all of them I think you
only have to do these four to get to get
this bracket and then I think it comes
out kind of like the screen did tilting
forward but there's many other parts in
here this here is the power supply this
here is uh what is this I don't actually
know I'd have to look here's the CD
drive here's a heatsink and down here
you can see there's another heat sink
this is probably where the CPU is on the
reverse side of the board and here's
probably where the GPU is on the reverse
side of this and this is just some sort
of interface board let's see what does
it go to kits power oh there's a
Bluetooth module a wireless module horse
fans speakers uh any other questions
just let me know in the comments below
I'm going to go ahead and finish taking
this drive out replace it with a new one
put everything back together I think
this video is long enough but it's not
too bad to get to the hard drive on this
model you really just need those suction
cups to get that initial screen off and
t6 on a t8 for these screws alright well
thank you for watching my video here on
code Tecna toriel's and my name is Matt
please like and subscribe if this helped
you or if you want to and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]